what's up guys this is eric griffin and
i want to give a big
shout out to helix sleep take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to the mattress that will give you
the best
sleep of your life find your perfect
mattress at helix helixsleep.com
griffin all right let's do it
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
[Music]
your favorite podcast
anyways welcome back to river mcgriffin
we got real world advice from a grown
ass man
rachel's on talking about valentine's
day
and it's just me doing my thing as usual
so i really appreciate y'all being here
once again listening to the podcast
supporting make sure you check me out
gaming every day on eric griffin gaming
on twitch
i put those videos up on youtube and i
just really appreciate y'all watching
[Music]
all right we did it again with
where griffin is back in the house thank
you another week
valentine's day was yesterday uh
i got some stuff about that on the on
the show so i hope that was good and uh
really that's about it
you know just a chill week i mean you
know not to get into politics but you
know they
acquitted donald trump and i i knew they
were going to do that anyway because
they weren't going to get enough
republican votes but you know whatever
it is what it is you have your if you
have your beliefs about it you have your
beliefs about it we'll see what happens
democracy moves on hopefully
and so uh you know there's nothing more
to even be said about that i'm not even
really
gonna get into it um damn what has been
going on
i finally agreed to do a show so i'm
gonna be at the
stand-up live in phoenix
the 25th 26th 27th i believe it is
and michael yeo is going to be there
with me so make sure you guys if you're
in that area
check it out but i got to tell you i'm
nervous about it
i really am nervous i don't know how
this
pandemic has affected you um
but for me i i've become a homebody i've
become like i just like being at home i
don't like going out because i don't
like
that i can't interact in the way i
normally do i'm very
up in your face i'm very touchy feely i
like to hug i'm that kind of person i
shake hands i greet people i like to be
up in their space and
you can't be like that now and it just
makes me feel awkward i don't i don't
know how to be and then
i can't perform the way i used to i used
to perform all the time and
you know you work on your material and i
now i just feel like i don't know
any of my jokes i'm trying to write new
jokes i'm trying to find like what am i
going to talk about i don't want to just
sit there and talk about covet for an
hour or you know
am i going to do all relationship
material i mean i don't even know
so i am nervous about who am i in comedy
right now being a funny guy so you know
it's
something weird about it um just the
other day i i actually did
tony baker and friends tony's been on
the podcast before tony baker is so
funny he does these
he does these animal videos on his
instagram all the time where he does the
voices
and you know he you know so he makes up
things that the animals are
doing it's just it's such a wholesome
fun good time so you really should go
check out tony baker's instagram because
you will laugh
i mean i find myself just getting lost
on his page so many times he's got like
a million some followers so i'm not the
only person that feels that way about
tony baker's
um his sensibility you know his comedy
so make sure you check that out so
i did a show and you know and it's like
this is like the new normal now so i had
to go down to the place
at 11 30 a.m get a covid test
which took like you know all of
two minutes really like i took more time
filling out the paperwork on my phone
than it did to actually do the covet
test
you know you know they say hey blow your
nose you know and then they just
gently stuck the thing in and then 10
minutes later i got a text on my phone
you're
you're you're negative you know and i
was like and that's and then that's how
you do it now
and then everybody at the show to even
come in the show had to get a covet test
because
i guess the tests are so readily
available now the technology is so
right there i mean i'm sure eventually
they're going to be selling this in cvs
you know where you just you know
before you do anything they'll be like
hey make sure you go down and get a
covet test you know bring it with you
and it's going to be
probably instant you just like you know
stick it in your nose you shake it and
then it'll be like a pregnancy test you
know what i mean it'll be like positive
negative
you know so that's the way it was so i
wasn't worried about that
i find myself not being worried about
the safety of things
recently anyway but i don't even know if
that's right is it is that like a false
sense of security because i've never
really been like super scared
um i guess i was in the beginning when
it was like
everybody stay at home but since then
looking at the numbers looking at the
information and just seeing it you just
kind of go i don't know
if this if this warrants the kind of
attention that it's getting
that's just the way you feel when you're
just when you're away from it like that
so
you know in this kind of situation i
wasn't necessarily worried about
my safety health and safety of myself
and others i was really worried about
like
the well-being of the show can i put on
a good show can i still be funny so
you know i got that show coming up and
believe me i've been every day i'm
jotting down notes on my notepad so
you know if you come out to see me in
phoenix it's going to be a
completely like different type of me i'm
really out there to like
you know work this out so i'm gonna have
to like make sure i record
you know all the shows and just so i can
have that because that's one thing i
really regret
is not recording more of my shows
because who would have thought that
you would not perform again for a year
like
really perform the way i was performing
before
who who would have known and then you
forget your jokes you forget the nuances
you forget the timing you forget like
you know you forget certain words that
you've like built up this repertoire
this like arsenal of uh little
inflections and things
that are part of your persona that you
do on stage it they just kind of
you forget them when you don't do it all
the time
so it's not like riding a bike
stand-up's really not like that it's
very nuanced you know my favorite word i
use it a lot and reference things
but anyways so i am going to be doing
that and so like i say i
am like legit putting it out there i am
legit
nervous about that but
you know we'll see how it goes right
i mean that's all you could uh i mean
that's all you can really like that's
all you can really do
so i don't know how you guys are out
there with your like whatever you're
doing
because this is just you know one of
those
you know this is just one of those
businesses that are that the
entertainment business that has
really been hit hard and
like when it comes back what is it going
to look like what are we going to be
i hope that it's just a matter of like
you know you have some really
simple fast covet test that it's just
going to be like all right so everybody
in here is
good sweet all right let's do a concert
let's do a show let's do it you know
what i mean
um i just i just want to get back to
that i missed that
i just i just really truly miss that
so boom there it is um
so uh on this week's episode i got like
i said i got a bunch of stuff
uh i got real world advice from a grown
ass man
that's back and i got the lovely rachel
is back with me talking about what we
did for valentine's day and you know
just
by the way check out her she got her own
vlog she only got two videos up so
and be nice like honestly like she's
just going to erase the comments anyway
because she's
i kept telling you you're not supposed
to do that but she doesn't care it's her
thing
you know if you know it's like everybody
thinks they have carp launch to be just
as rude as they want to be to anybody
you know
you know this these uh keyboard warriors
uh because i get them all on my thing
all the time you know they they like
i love when people like to take your
words parse them make them make them out
to be whatever you want them to be
and then they and then they like put it
put things out
actually i just you know what's funny
this is something i didn't want to talk
about
i'm not even going to publicize it
because it doesn't even it doesn't even
matter and like why give
people more ammunition to do dumb [ __ ]
but like
i actually saw a video of a guy
doing a reaction video to my podcast
you know and it was so bizarre because i
was like wow
like you really and it was so crazy
because the dude
totally took everything out of context
he like he like made it
into what he wanted it to be and you
know and he's weird he's got he he wears
sunglasses
in his video you know what i mean i
thought i was like what is this are you
doing like what are you doing this for
do you
it was weird cause i was like does this
guy really believe the nonsense that
he's saying
about what i'm what he thinks i'm saying
that was that was the thing about it was
like and i thought oh how cool
am i i'm famous enough that i'm getting
a reaction video from a troll
i was like oh oh okay thank you
but the weird thing about a reaction
video about
someone doing a podcast is like if
it's not even like like the dude totally
like put words in my mouth you know like
he
he made it out to be what he wanted it
to be but i'm thinking to myself and
then
i looked at some of the comments and
that's what the comments were people
were saying like
yo dude you're making you're this is a
stretch you're putting words in the
guy's mouth
but i thought to myself why watch that
video
like if the guy puts out a statement and
he says oh this guy is
a b and c and he's using a video of me
to prove his point then why don't you as
a viewer
go from that and go well let me go check
this out for myself
you know what i mean like just watch my
video that you could be like
oh actually that's not what he was
saying and you could
you have your own opinion because he
basically took like i was answering a
question from real world advice from a
grown ass man
i was answering someone's question
making a point about something else
and he used that point to make it like
he took that and made it about
another point and i thought and i'm not
even going to say what it's about
because i don't think it's worthy of
that
um but anyway my point is just like it's
just weird that people have
you know people use like because a
podcast is a sort of
format that you can formulate your own
opinion by watching it
agreement disagreement um you know
someplace in the middle so you could
do that but to watch someone else
formulate their own opinion i guess you
could watch that too
if you are a fan of that person like if
you're a fan of me and you want to watch
me make like like like i want to do
movie reviews for instance
so if you trust my opinion you go well i
want to hear what you have to say about
a movie
even if you go oh i like what you're
saying about this i disagree i thought
the movie was bad if i think it was good
that's one thing
but it's another thing to like you know
listen to somebody like like like if i
made a movie like if i talk
if i said finding new well finding nemo
was really about
uh you know the government you know you
know
you know whisking away children who have
come across the border like if i
turn to finding nemo into something
completely different you might be like
well whoa what are you talking about
that's kind of what this guy does you
know so it's like i kind of feel like
why
you know if you do come across a video
like that
for anyone if you're watching a reaction
video of somebody
looking at somebody's podcast i do
highly suggest
you just go to that podcast and listen
to it for yourself because i'm telling
you most of the time
people are taking your words out of
context
to make themselves for whatever reason
they're doing you know
like you know people love to like um you
know they're trying to promote
themselves you know they're trying to
they're trying to like stir up some
controversy to make people
watch them more you know there's a lot
of them out there like that there's
actually
quite a few people who do this they just
look at podcasts and then they
trash them they trash the podcast they
trash the guests
to build up their own brand but that's
their brand i mean i get it you know
what i mean
it's trent what i'm saying is it's very
transparent
it's kind of like government when you're
looking at a politician who won't answer
a question
you know like a politician and you kind
of go oh well you're doing that politics
thing and you just
like i think we're just more savvy now
as human beings
that we get what people are doing so
this is the same kind of thing so these
like kind of like
shock jock podcast trashers you know
they think that they're doing something
really profound but like
we get it like everyone that watches is
at home like oh you don't like this guy
or oh you're really doing this because
you're trying to like you know
you're trying to be controversial like
and so if you like that kind of stuff
it's like watching like i like watching
reality tv for the same reason
i like the train wreck of it so i just
think that it's like
it's i i hope that those people are
self-aware enough to know
i think some of them are this one guy i
know is i kind of feel like he's
self-aware he knows what he's doing you
know what i mean
you know he knows that he's like poking
the bear and like doing that you know
so i can almost appreciate that and
there's some that are like this one guy
i'm talking about who's just
really i don't know if he's i don't know
if he's living in his own universe
uh you know but i don't know i think
i think if you're making a podcast where
you're like parsing people's words
and changing the narrative you know what
you're doing
so you're actually a piece of [ __ ] you
know what i mean if you really think
about it
because you're like making something
that it's not you know but i guess that
happens all the time on the news you
know
you know it's like fox news does this
all the time on the opinion shows you
know
not just fox news by the way they may
not even say it like that because cnn
and all these people do the same thing
don lemon
uh you know all the way to sean hannity
they're all they all do the same thing
they take things and they
change the narrative and so that's the
the nature of the beast right now and so
i guess they do it on the smaller way
smaller smaller scale take you know
trying to make
weird points looking at people's podcast
so but anyways
god i went off on a tangent on that but
anyways let's move on uh like i said
uh up next is the lovely rachel and then
real world advice from a grown ass man
and thanks for being here
what's up guys are you sleeping on an
old soggy
saggy ass mattress that you've had
forever
she's not comfortable your neck hurts
your back hurts
well i'm here to talk to you right now
about helix
sleep i got a healed seat mattress you
should get one too
it will give you the best sleep of your
life and it's important to get some good
sleep right now especially in these
crazy times you know what i mean
it's like we're not able to sleep
because of politics to pandemic
and trials and insurrections and
your love life we just had valentine's
day and so maybe
you had a great one and maybe you had a
bad one and you need to like
sleep it off well where are you sleeping
it's important
helix sleep you know the thing that i
love about them the most is they have
this
sleep quiz that's the thing it's a two
minute quiz you complete it out and it
matches you to your body type your body
style
are you big or you're small or you're
fat or you're do you sleep on your side
you sleep on your stomach
i'm a side sleeper so i have this one i
got is the softest mattress i've ever
slept on
and i highly recommend that you guys get
this so
everybody's unique and helix knows it so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium firm like i said so
i took to see the i took the quiz
you should take it too even if you don't
buy go take the quiz and find out
what type of mattress is right for you
i love it it was a huge upgrade so
if you're looking for a match mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
and they'll match it to it to you it
makes it right for you
and they'll drop it off at your door for
free you don't ever have to go to the
mattress store again because you know
that's
the stupidest part you go to the
mattress store what do you have to lay
in a mattress in the middle of the place
you don't even know if that's going to
be the one you're going to get
taking this quiz is the best part of the
whole thing and to take it all away
they take all that nonsense away of
going to the store they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights
risk fee they'll even pick it up for you
if you don't love it
but you're gonna love it helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com griffin that's the
important part right there guys
make sure you go to helix helixleep.com
griffin for the best sleep of your life
take it from me let's get back to the
show
so what are you saying valentine's what
are you talking about valentine's day
valentine's valentine's day
it's just singing why
i spilled something on my shirt at
dinner
i don't know i think it was mashed
potatoes i think it was the mat
the uh gravy from the mashed potatoes oh
peppercorn sauce oh the peppercorns
the peppercorn sauce was for the steak
but we put it on the potatoes
because we're different like that
thank you very much there you go and
welcome
back to the podcast your another
favorite podcast
wait are you trying to do my intro what
do you say welcome back to your favorite
podcast
you know the name and then the music
plays yeah i hit the music
no there's no music on this section so
we just got back it's valentine's
day night and we had our beautiful
valentine's dinner we went to a
kosher i don't know if it was it was
kosher was it french
kosher steakhouse french kosher
steakhouse
and so like it was called shiloh shy
shout out to shiloh's it was good it was
very great it was good right
and then like they had like the parking
lot so there's no more parking lot
because they had like plants around the
parking lot and they had this
tent flap up and then like they had like
the heat lamps and the plants and
it was really it was really nice right
they made the best of this
covid situation yeah at first i was a
little hesitant
because i've never been to the
restaurant yeah yeah we don't know what
the food was like and everything like
that
but since we've already gone through it
it was can you please keep the mic in
front of your face like stop moving away
from it
this is the wrong chair to sit in
because it moves
no but i'm just going to try to sit up
check it out even when i move i keep the
mic look like i'm still talking right
into the microphone you're professional
how many podcasts have you done yeah but
aren't you professional this is number
four
with your new channel which you can find
on youtube rachel's claw
thank you for the vlog
she's got two weird videos up already
i'm glad you described them as weird
they are a little weird
they're weird but this is cute we so we
had
so yesterday because she couldn't wait
first of all
i couldn't wait you were the one who let
me choose and then you like ran to your
car to go get the present well we first
of all i
okay start from the beginning well we
were gonna have i thought it was gonna
be a low-key valentine's but then you
you were all like well i've already got
your gift then i was like oh [ __ ] i
gotta get a gift
it just remind you know us because we've
been indoors so much and we're always
together
you forget about like what you forget
about the real stuff like the normal
life
and try to have as much normalcy as
possible so you do all that
stuff so i did go out and get rachel
a gift and she got me a gift
yeah um and it was nice and then we like
exchanged gifts
for me when i buy rachel giff the real
thing is
i like seeing her reaction and she had
the best reaction it was the exact
reaction that i thought
she would have are you going to show the
video
that's kind of embarrassing yeah i don't
know if i'll show that video they don't
need to know everything about our lives
but anyways
you know i gave her i got her a necklace
from tiffany's you want to you want to
show it
i am wearing it um we don't see it
though
next year it will be bigger right
they'll see it from this far away
no you don't like it this is why people
say things about you
[Laughter]
by the way by the way the comment
section
is full of like gold digger comments and
it's that kind of attitude
no i love it i don't want anything else
this is perfect
whatever it doesn't matter so i went to
okay so the other day we were sitting
and looking she was talking about she
wanted a louis vuitton bag
and i'm like i don't get bags i don't
get why women like bags
i don't get why do women like bags well
it's just
part of our outfit we just grown used to
like
you get dressed and then you grab a
purse and you put all your stuff in the
purse
yeah but for the day so it carries our
keys our wallet
our cell phone anything else we want to
put in it
and so like no no that has nothing to do
with why women like
bags why do you like different bags why
do you have to have new purses
why like what is it about the purse it's
kind of like
keeping up with the joneses you know you
just want
the next oh so it's a fashion thing yeah
the next best thing like shoes same
same as okay i guess i guess i can
understand that there are guys that are
sneaker heads
yeah so but did this they're so
expensive new things come out and you're
like oh
right so rachel says she wants the louis
vuitton bag no but she doesn't say that
she wanted me to get her louboutin back
she's like very passive aggressive like
oh i've never had a little time about
you know that kind of thing
well okay you're putting it in weird
perspective as well because like i'm
very motivated
by like fashion and um
like i i work
full-time no you don't okay work
part-time right now
we're trying to put out lies out there i
work
time no you know she goes i work and now
i have full time now i have nine days
you have part time
full-time part but it's not even her
fault if you could work full-time you
would it's just that they're just not
there's no hours weird hours retail
during the season okay but anyways you
you said you so it's about fashion okay
so you
right so i would save up my money to buy
like a dream purse what's a dream purse
well that's what i was like watching
these videos to figure out like
what because some persons you can buy
and actually
make money off of them later on oh which
i didn't know that that was a tough sale
i didn't know that that was sometimes
like some person's
like the hermes was that how you say it
old me i don't even know but it's
spelled like h-e-r-m-e-s
oh but it's french better excuse me
sorry blue well we went to a french
breeze
i had a guest
[Laughter]
so you went okay so you so then you
could buy a purse like that
and then if it becomes real trendy like
i was watching this one video right
before you walked in
and they were saying how she
bought this bag and immediately went
online to see how much
it was like people were selling it for
and it was already double the amount
just from like wow just
because it's so hard to get oh you got
to be in the purse business then
yeah so like well the resale purse
business
right but anyway so she's looking at
these videos but you also like it
if you want to resell these persons you
have to like keep them pristine
like well that's your check off to check
you off because
right i really use my things like even
cars you know like if you're gonna buy
something expensive jeans
like i really like to wear them and get
used out of it yeah she's worn the
grooves off those eight hundred dollar
jeans
they're they're two-dimensional yeah
so she's watching this purse thing and i
go what is it with the purses and then
i'm like what then she's talking we
start talking about louis vuitton
then i went to the louis vuitton website
and then there was just i was like oh
god this is ridiculous a hot pink person
she was like i've always wanted a hot
pink purse
so i had that in my head so i went down
to
um third street promenade and they have
um a louis vuitton store i actually went
to the louis vuitton store
you know i've never even been in the
louisiana store and it's weird right now
they got all this covered procedures
and there's probably like a line outside
the door no no no no there wasn't a line
because you you put you had to sign up
they got your phone number they had it
in the computer
and then a text message would come out
and be like please show up to the store
in five minutes we left at the same time
to go shopping for each other
and i was like crossing my fingers
hoping we wouldn't end up at the same
well that would have been great so i
went to louis vuitton
and then i was looking up the bags and i
saw the little hot pink bag that
that we had looked at but it just was
like it was little and it was like i was
like i don't know if you'll really
like this so i told the guy
hey all right i'm looking at this give
me your card so i got the guy's card and
i was like i need to go look at another
store man because i have an idea for a
gift
so oh wait wait no no what happened was
when i was waiting for louis vuitton i
went over to tiffany's
then i saw this guy there tiffany he was
like what do you mean while you were
waiting for them they made you wait
yeah yeah you couldn't just go in it was
like it was like you had to make a
impromptu appointment oh got it to make
sure there's only a few people in the
store
yeah so i did i put my information i
said okay i'll be back i went to
tiffany's which was literally literally
right across
and then i started looking around there
and it was like ridiculous and i said to
the guy look man this is the range price
range he was like oh don't worry we got
everything you need and i was like oh
okay he opens up the thing and he starts
pulling out stuff
and i was like i love that you know he
pulled two out and i was like
that's you know then he showed me this
one and i was like oh that's it it was
right in the range
that i was willing to pay
[Laughter]
a little bit more and then i said okay i
said listen man
it's between this and a bag can you hold
this for me
and he was like don't worry just ask for
me and then i went back
over there and i actually looked at all
the stuff and then it was like he was
showing me like
and i just i didn't know what to get you
know i
you know you know he was like well this
is in season to me
i just had no knowledge to be like let
me get this per oh that's the one
and then he was showing me like well
there's other things there's necklaces
and i was like i'm not getting a louis
vuitton necklace
why not see to me to me it's like
you go to louis vuitton you go to get a
bag you don't go to get
anything else yeah i mean they had shoes
they had all kinds of stuff and i was
like all right
what what is all this so i said okay
look dude
i gotta go back over to tiffany's so i
can decide he was like cool
said but give me your card though but
but i already knew
i walked out of there like i'm going to
get and then the guy
over tim he actually knew too he had it
ready ready
you know what i mean he was like i knew
you'd be back that kind of vibe
and i was like okay so then he wrapped
that up i i stayed a little while and
looked at some other things
by the way so i have a guy now i have a
tiffany's guy
good i'm glad you finally found your
titties man
i got a guy so for that and so then um
anyways well that's what they were
saying in these like youtube
purse things too is that you have to
um buy other purchases at the store
prior to like
the purse you want why i don't know it's
really weird that's why i was watching
all these weird purse videos
yeah she's like just these random chicks
who like they do
all of them do the podcast in the same
place from their closet
yeah and there's like expensive purses
in the background and they're just like
talking about purses and it's just like
i i don't get it but there's just
there's an audience for everything out
there obviously
yeah if you have the money then might as
well
enjoy enjoy the horse collections so
i got it and then it was like you know
i i then i was excited and then she like
doesn't like surprises so i was making
it a surprise i was like guess what i
got using the knife there's gonna be
easy brides and she was like show me now
and i was like no
you know then we waited the next day and
then she got me something and so then
yesterday we did it yesterday right
yesterday the day before event
we just broke down i was like okay let's
exchange gifts well there was also a
reason because i was about to like
release my video on rachel sklar on
youtube
her new valentine's video and you can
see the new year's video that her little
vlog that she made she's trying to build
up her own channel
let's support her fellas don't be rude
be if you're gonna be rude and
disrespectful
that's for here but for her she needs
nice positive
positivity because she'll just erase
your comment anyway
so you're wasting your time
it's for them yeah yeah yeah if you want
to do it for yourself
so i got the
so then so then i gave her the gift and
i
recorded it i'm not gonna show you right
because like you know i
didn't i knew my gift was going to be
ruined
um oh yeah right because she talked
about her gift on
her her vlog so she wanted to release it
so we exchanged gifts
so i went downstairs i left it in my car
because just she's sneaky as hell
and actually i'm glad i did because okay
let's talk about what she got me first
she got me oh i don't even have it with
me but she got me a really nice leather
wallet
a nice wallet but you know you know i
mean she's like so all the things i want
to take from you it should be in this
kitty
that's rude that's a joke
that's a joke they're gonna make rachel
every every all the dumb jokes that are
gonna happen right now are gonna be
about oh she got you a wallet so she can
take everything out you know i saw that
nonsense but anyway
so she got me a nice wallet it's really
nice
you know what i mean like it's actually
really nice wallet but
she checked she looked at my wallet
first to see what kind of wallet i had
okay well let me describe this story
okay so i
when i was going wallet hunting for him
i realized that i never look into his
wallet to see if he has an id
holder or like flaps for cash
i just numbers of other women i just
don't know how many credit card holders
he needed
you know any all that stuff that you
think is just like
not important it's very important when
you're shopping for someone else
because you don't want them to like
not like it and i've definitely gotten
you so many gifts that you didn't like
you mean like the 18 candles every
that's just an
easy gift anyways so
so what she did was she looked at my
wallet and i had the tiffany's
card for the tiffany's guy in the wallet
yeah as soon as i got home
i mean it was too late to like return
the present but
yeah so i just wanted to like see what
was in his wallet
like how it was laid out and i opened it
totally saw the tiffany's card
from the store totally thought you were
gonna propose
i was getting ready i was like
i was like this is it yeah
like but then i felt so guilty i like
immediately shut your wallet
yeah see cause you wouldn't see now i
know this is why i told her you didn't
wanna like no no no no
i'm stepping in this is what i told her
when i do actually officially propose
with a ring
you're never gonna know it's not gonna
be on her birthday
it's not gonna be on a special holiday
it's just gonna come out of nowhere and
it's gonna be special and nice because
now i know how sneaky you are okay so
june maybe see
don't don't try to control it like when
there's not a holiday it should be
something weird off the beaten path
but anyways i got her a nice necklace i
brought it upstairs in the bag i was
filming her because i knew what she
would do she would start crying and of
course she did
she was like this is the best she's so
sweet
and then she but then she filmed me
which you can see her video because she
got
well she gave me the wallet check out my
blog at
my youtube yeah look at the link down
below because she gave me like
fancy face masks and i was like of
course this is the kind of gift men
get especially now that you've like
tested one out
the maths are great actually they're
actually really good size they fit my
face better you're welcome
i know but that's not a g okay it's a
gift
it's a very nice mess that you love to
wear
are you kidding me that is not a good
gift for someone
that's something you just get them you
should just get those because i need
them that is like
the specialness of like oh here's your
valentine's gift the mask that you need
to wear by law
no but you don't really need to wear it
you could wear a cloth mask you could
wear
like your underwear at target i've seen
someone with
what i'm saying um underwear over their
face as a mask
well that's disgusting well hopefully
it's a clean
pair but i don't know i've tried yours
when you're not around
i go to the dirty clothes hamper and
that's disgusting you love it so i
she gave me her gift i gave her her gift
and it was really sweet you know
and then we consummated the relationship
because i knew it would be full tonight
i knew we would come back from a
steakhouse and just be tired and you
know
and we went to this place tonight and it
was it was really nice like i said it
was set up nice the food was delicious
i knew she'd be full because they gave
us two appetites they had a valentine's
menu
and so it was like just salmon carpaccio
with this like
like sort of pork thing i don't know if
it was pork but it was like some kind of
beef bacon or whatever it was
no it was yeah it was a beef bacon um
with like a cream sauce
that was probably it was not dairy but
well anyway it was delicious it tastes
like pizza kind of
she ate all the salmon so i knew i saw
her you told me i could have it i know
but you're gonna be i know you're gonna
be full she always has her her eyes are
bigger than her stomach
okay so then we got the steak she only
ate like a little bit of it but i knew
she was gonna enjoy it
it was really great time it was
delicious and then we went to the weed
store
and then um you know we had a good uh
i got i got my little cbd
a little bit of i got a 1 8 mix
and then here we are back at home and i
said let's just jump right on the
podcast and
you know share our delicious valentine's
evening with everybody and she looks
great you know you know he likes hands
down you know what the thing is about
right now because everything's outside
because i saw a girl walk in the
restaurant and she had on like a
a [ __ ] dress and i thought that's not
comfortable because it was cold
even though you had the heat lamps
that's the the the thing you have to
think about when you go
so she wanted to wear like a beautiful
dress but i was like be comfortable it's
better for us to be
because she gets cold no okay first i
was
like in comfortable clothes and then i
was like you know what i should dress up
and so i like then put on a dress and
then i was like yeah
and that's when you came in and were
like you're crazy yeah because you're
gonna be freezing
and even she thought this little sweater
was enough and we had to go get a jacket
you brushed up you were like i'm glad i
brought my jacket i
was glad i brought my jacket but i just
like had my jacket on my lap
like a little blanket because they put
the heat lamp
and this is a an interesting get up you
have on
with the pink it is what it is i i spent
all my money on that wallet
that some of those face masks
there was no need to get extra clothes
like rachel
has a walk-in closet full of [ __ ]
and when it's time to go someplace she
walks in there and goes i have nothing
to do
but you don't understand explain it to
me okay
so i've never really made a ton of money
in my life and so i've
worked hard and
i've like spent some money on
some clothes right um as investments
of stuff that will last a long time
and so all my clothes have probably
lasted me
at least 10 years of my life already if
not more
and so that's why i'm like at a point
where i'm kind of like
like i'm moving up a size so
so that's a lot of that's a cute way to
say it fitting
right i'm moving up a size and
yeah she put on it yeah you put on an
outfit yesterday like you know
grown up wear okay she put on alpha
yesterday i was like oh no
i can't i can't fit this this was all i
used to write i went back to my
i had a great idea of what i was gonna
wear it was in my closet
at my parents house i went home to get a
bunch of like
my dresses that i didn't have um
at this place and i brought them home
tried them on yesterday
none of them fit zero
like 10-0
[Laughter]
because you thick as hell now girl
no i was really skinny yeah and she was
like a like a rail
but that's what i'm saying like like one
of those commercials where you have to
send 99 cents a month that's how skinny
she was
skinny legend was my tick tock
comment skinny legend so now you're uh
now you yeah you look at this woman this
is this is good this is a good thing
though
um but there's still people out there
looking at you like are you kidding me
no i'm still skinny
i feel skinny but um it was a great time
i'm glad we and i hope you all enjoyed
your valentine's out there
whatever you did yesterday and for the
single people too you know i
like i was answering some questions on
and because make sure you stick around
for real world advice from a grown ass
um i don't know if i'm gonna do this
before or after who knows whatever
if this could be weird editing right now
what i just did but it doesn't matter
um you know valentine's day is not just
for couples you know you know you can
you know what do they call it what's
that other galentines
yeah that's for just where the girls get
together yeah and we talk [ __ ] about all
boys
no um i mean when when
like two years ago when we weren't
together that valentine's day
i went to this really cool place called
the breakup bar
it was like just like a valentine's day
themed
bar in hollywood for like that short
month
like just a february and it was like
super cool like
i went with my girlfriends and um
so what you just like to be single and
not
care about so what idiot guys when it
came up to you none
that that was like that's the whole
point of it they tell you when you come
in
do not hit on anyone well no that's not
like the theme
but like everyone's just
everyone's just trying to be chill
everyone keeps to themselves in l.a just
but i just feel like it's okay to like
you know for your
family and really close friends to be
like hey here's a valentine's gift or
just a shout out like hey
i care about you i'm thinking about you
i mean i think the holidays are really
for that
and then if you're a couple you know
it's just heightened the the
the friendship and love that you already
share with somebody that you truly care
about
that's what the holiday is about so i
hope you guys enjoyed that
and uh you know i thank my beautiful my
beautiful fiancee for coming on the
podcast again
and make sure you check out her blog her
vlog
she don't know what it is yet so you
just got to keep going and support her
giving her something you know what i
mean it will eventually become something
it'll eventually become something but
for now it's just like her doing like
these little weird videos in her
yoga room my creative space
not a minute of yoga got done in there
yet but she
i've done yoga i've done three online
okay
okay i have a yoga subscription
yeah got it a more waste of money
so i hope you i hope you enjoy that so
make sure you check her out and thanks
for
watching um this and
um look out for coming up next
real world advice from a grown ass man
thank you all right y'all and here it is
real world advice from a grown ass man
it's been like over a month but we're
back
valentine's edition even though none of
these questions are
none of these questions actually had to
do with valentine's day well actually
some of them do
um but yeah so uh thanks for being
involved in this you know like i always
say uh
i'm no expert so if you uh really need
some help
if you're having some uh real serious
troubles anxiety depression or
any sort of things that have to do with
mood i really highly suggest you uh go
out there and get
some professional help it will be
beneficial to your life
if i know that therapy sometimes has a
stigma or you come from a family that
you're like oh we take care of our
problems ourselves but take it from me
i've done it
many times it is really helpful helps
you just organize your thoughts with a
professional to help you understand
why you feel the way you feel and that's
really what it is it doesn't necessarily
solve your problems but if you
understand the origin
the root of some problems sometimes that
helps you on the path to uh
figuring it out yourself get you on the
path to
have some self-awareness and some
understanding so i highly do recommend
that but all in good fun when we do
real-world advice from a grown-ass man
normally okay you know you know what i
mean
so i just have to say that because
sometimes i get some really serious
questions and i go whoa
let me put that disclaimer out there all
right first up
i've been struggling to talk to girls
over the phone or through text
any advice or or good ice breakers
is what i guess he was trying to say
there with that last word um
well you know you know it's like man i
just come from a different generation
where
you know we just met people in a
different way
i'm in like the middle of my age range
we're in the middle we've seen so many
things
change over this lifetime so there's
like a 20-year span
you know from 20s to 40s that like just
the world just
really exploded cell phones and
computers and and the advancement of
technology
my generation really has seen the
beginning of it and now we're
knee-deep in it and we don't know where
it's going to go from here so you know i
come from an era where we had to talk on
a phone it wasn't such a strange thing
because it was the only way to talk to
somebody
you got somebody's number like you had
to carry a pen you know you had to go to
bars you had to meet people
you know they're you know they had these
like newspaper personal ads but
can you imagine how dangerous that would
feel right now to like get an ad in the
newspaper and be like oh yo
you know oh let me go meet this person
someplace i mean it's just so weird
right
you know for you people now that are
used to what it is right now so
if you just think of it that way is that
it's not that unusual it's just a form
of communication so
so i know it's hard but you know just
when you text
you know just text
don't text yes or no questions or or
questions that'll be like one word
answer you know get in depth you know
it's like
how you know don't be like did you have
a good day
that's like yes or no talk about your
day hey i had a great day
i did this this and this and uh this
made me think of you
uh how you know what was going on on
your day or you know man i went and got
some coffee today and i had this kind of
coffee and this strange thing happened
like you know it's like
just be be normal you know
spark up a conversation that way you
know you don't have to be brilliant
in every single text message you know
you don't got to solve uh you know covid
in your text message you're just
you're just reaching out being
thoughtful so be thoughtful let the
person know hey i'm thinking about you
and this is why i'm thinking about you
you know and so those are just like
the my general tips in terms of that and
just like you know be yourself
you know i know like these
this generation has trouble again
talking on the phone because you're not
used to it
you used to just click click click click
click click but like it is normal to be
in front of somebody and being like hey
how you doing and like
reading all that nuance and and reading
all the facial expressions and trying to
like understand
where somebody's coming from with your
body language oh it's the same kind of
thing over the phone there's a certain
uh weird verbal language that people
have when you're on the phone you know
when you're comfortable
and it's i think it's important to like
get on the phone right away so
if you can get on the phone with whoever
this is whoever you're
meeting with and just being like hey how
you doing try to get on facetime
try to get on some kind of video message
and just be like just talk hey
smile you know hey you look great uh how
was your day uh you know you know what i
mean
just take a breath relax
be yourself you know just try to be
yourself just try to be comfortable
try to be thoughtful try to be just and
also
listen don't just wait to talk listen
what's this person saying if you don't
know what to talk about let that person
take the lead in the sense of being like
hey how was your day and they say oh
i did this this and this and you go oh
that sounds interesting like is that
what you normally do at work or like
tell me about your job or
oh man that might inspire you then to
start talking about something about
yourself
oh that reminds me of this just just be
open to the conversation and let it flow
man let it flow it's like a dance
you know it takes listening processing
and then asking or
responding or asking your own question
okay but good luck out there man
good luck
all right here's a good one
a friend recently gave me unsolicited
criticism
it kind of [ __ ] up my self-confidence
all right i guess
you know this is one of these things
as a public figure uh if if i may you
know i'm not saying i'm famous or
anything like that but i am a public
figure because i got something out like
this and thousands of people watch it
i get a lot of unsolicited
you know advice you know people give a
lot of unsolicited advice people hit you
up like yo man i don't like your
the lighting i don't like the sound i
don't like your mic i don't like your
shirts i think you're
you know i get things like you [ __ ] too
much or you know it's like man you
complain all the time or
all these kinds of things now listen
unsolicited advice
comes at you all the time but it don't
mean it's wrong
you know what i mean so it's like how
you take it like
like people don't understand that it's
like if you don't like my shirt
so i picked out my shirt i went into the
closet like oh i like this shirt i'm
gonna wear this shirt
i bought this shirt just my favorite
shirt and you come hit me with
damn that shirt's ugly or it makes you
look fat it's okay for me to take a
second and be like
damn why you all on me like that it's
okay for me to take that second
as long as you then can step away from
it and be like okay
does what this person is saying have
merit does this shirt make me look fat
does this shirt is it a bad color for me
it's okay to take a
second and process that information and
be like
huh take your own time to be like well
you know what there is some truth in
that
and i then i will act on it if i choose
to act on it
but how we talk to each other
is really what this question is about
you know
and then sometimes people lack tact
sometimes people lack
um sensitivity to people's feelings
some people think like i always say this
just because like i hate when somebody
says oh i'm just being honest
hey being honest doesn't excuse you
from being an [ __ ] so
it's okay if i have a reaction
to how you came at me you're coming at
me funky
so that puts me in a funky mood but at
the same time
if i could step away from that and go
hey that person was a dick
i didn't like how they said that to me
but is there some merit in what they
said
if you can achieve that if you can get
to that i highly suggest it
and then the other people on the other
side of that for you people out there
that think
oh you being the truth teller i'm just
telling it like it is
you have to remember that you know
there's consequences of that and i live
that all the time because i'll say
something and then somebody will give me
a comment oh you're so rude or whatever
they might say i have to think about
that too and be like okay i didn't that
didn't come across the way i wanted it
to come across
no matter if i have merit or what i'm
saying no matter if if what i said
is truthful or not how we say things is
important
so you have to remember that too when
you're also the person receiving stuff
it's okay to have a reaction to how
somebody came at you but try to find a
way to step away from that and be like
does this have merit you know and then
if it's a real good friend
it's okay for you to come at that person
and be like yo man thanks for telling me
that but
i didn't like how you said it to me
because that's honest too
that's honest and that's how you can
really build your relationship
and move forward in a positive way so
that's my advice there man i can always
say
good luck
all right here's one love the stream
slash podcast you got any funny cringe
valentine's day stories
listen every guy has been in this
situation where
valentine's day is coming up
and you sitting here like damn i didn't
plan anything
man so then you're just sitting here
like
then last minute you're trying to get
reservations in places like right now
i'm sure
it's like a real hassle you know
cause like there's only certain number
tables of these outside seating and that
kind of stuff you know so you like
if you didn't plan ahead you you're
really gonna be in trouble so
you know i've had a situation like that
where it was like
i don't know what the hell to do didn't
make reservations
and so then you had to like improvise
you know every guy has been in that
situation with you driving by the
you driving by the gas station and you
see the flowers and teddy bear
so you know you grab that boom got this
i mean none of that is thoughtful right
it's just on how you present it so i've
been in a situation where i was like yo
i got you these flowers and teddy bear
you know what we gonna do
i'm taking you on a drive down the coast
and just whatever restaurant we see
that we think you know that we think
sparks our fancy
we gonna go in there and we go you know
it's just in my mind i know that this is
terrible
but i tried to like you know make it
seem like
this was the plan all along
[Laughter]
but i could tell looking back you know
it was like one of those things it was
like oh you didn't
you didn't plan anything did you and i
was like yeah but i'm trying you know
what i mean
i mean it's all it's all thoughtfulness
you know like i said it's all on how you
present it
you know like like valentine's day
really is about what's going on
do you know this person you know like
what's their favorite thing
it's like if you let's say you always
make like there's a
you once in a while you make a certain
type of pancake you make it a certain
way and she
loves it you know well valentine's day
is the time you spring that recipe out
it's simple
it's you know it's not about how much
money you spend it's not about
you know the fancy or the restaurant no
it's really just about
showing and making that first and pills
feel special in a way
that shows that you really know them and
listen to them
that is the real key so i'm usually like
that i don't
i don't have too many like korean
stories but i do remember that time that
like
you know like i say you just not
prepared you completely forgot you put
it off to the side because a lot of guys
are like man valentine's day
sucks it's just a you know it's just
another corporate holiday
to like get our money you know it's like
yeah i get it
but at the same time if she loves it she
loves it
so it's like you gotta do something that
day
it's like it's like it sucks but it is
what it is
you know so it's just better to embrace
it and just so you can avoid these like
cringy
things because i know that from i just
feel like
any time there's a bad valentine's day
story
it's like usually surrounded by the guy
forgetting to do anything or thinking oh
it'll be okay i'll get this done
and then we've all been there man it's
like
you know four days before valentine's we
go come on all the restaurants can't be
booked up
and you're calling or looking online and
it's like sold out sold out sold out or
to be some [ __ ]
time you know it's like 4 15 p.m
so then you all like girl we're going to
we're going to dinner
so be ready by 3 25 because we going to
the restaurant
you know so then you got to sell your
nonsense you got to sell that you uh
messed up so
that's usually how that goes but anyways
thanks also for the compliments about
the stream in the stream she means eric
griffin gaming so make sure you check
that out on twitch
next one how do comics feel about the
instant comic
comedic fame some of these tick tock
youtube kids got
i mean there's two schools of thought on
this you know you could be myopic and
think like
this is the only way you're supposed to
make it you know you have to do it this
way
and initially at first i know that it
was like that for a lot of comics i feel
like you know because
there was a way we had to work hard to
get into the clubs and then
you know we busted our ass we had to
write jokes and it was just like
this this um you know and then you think
that there's this love affair with the
art form
and you're being compensated for the art
form but what you find out is that we're
not really being compensated for the art
form so much as we're being compensated
for
um you know how it's
presented and that comes with a lot of
things it comes with like looks
you know i mean if you talk talent
versus attractiveness
talent versus sexiness the entertainment
business
you know it's all about it's it's not
necessarily always about the talent so
much is all about the appearance
this is an appearance based business so
you know that is a part of it
so you know i mean like you know the
doctor couldn't be like that you know
what i'm saying
like do you want the hot doctor that
don't know how to be a doctor
or do you want the you know the ugly one
who is like a genius in his field
for something like that you wouldn't
even hesitate you'd be like yeah yeah
give me the one that knows what he's
doing
but for some reason in entertainment
that's not the case
you know what i mean because there's
plenty of examples like look at the show
gossip girl
i mean terrible sorry to say for all you
gossip girl fans but
there's shows like that where you go
everybody on the show is hot
but this is the worst acting i've ever
seen in my life but we don't care
because we like looking at hot people do
hot people stuff
so there is sometimes you see things
that you like on television and
entertainment and there's a lack of
talent
but there something else comes with okay
so that being said what does that apply
to this
look it happens even in our own business
right now there's people who i think
aren't that funny but they have a
following
you know there's people that i think are
not good at
stand-up comedy that are out here with
they're they're selling out comedy clubs
and they're you know they got a
following they people
love their podcast or whatever it is so
i have to come to this realization that
like that there that it's all connected
that
people you know that's why when you see
somebody who is talented
and attractive and those two things
merge you're talking about that's the
people that
really are successful and i totally get
that so at a certain point you just have
to embrace
it is what it is this is the age of
technology this is like
it ain't even about people appreciating
you to your talent it's about
how can i get my talent out to as many
people as possible
and find my audience these youtuber tick
tock people they've taken advantage of
it
they have found their audience they know
how to they know how to
uh handle their they know how to like
handle the technology they know how to
like they know their message and their
brand and they found people who like it
and they found a way to monetize their
personality
you know these old school comic
mentality and entertainment we got to
just get over it and move on
and a lot of people have because like i
said there's a lot of comics now who
pre-podcasts were just like all right
you know you're funny you know what i
mean you know it's like
i i wouldn't necessarily see you being a
superstar uh
what you know whatever but then they
they got a podcast
that just blew them up in a sense of
like
they reached a large audience that
wanted to hear what they had to say
appreciated them for who they are and
now they have this niche audience that
has made them wealthy and famous
within this world so it is what it is
even in the comedic world so if you have
some star out there who's found a way to
monetize their personality
and now they're out here doing it hey it
is what it is
you know i got no hate for it you know
it just makes me go damn how do i find
my audience and i'm still struggling
with that you know it's like damn
you know it's like do i i wish my i had
a big old huge podcast with like you
know 300 000
you know views every single week you
know so i'm still trying to find
what is that thing that you know i have
to do you know
you just have to just keep going and
keep doing what you do and also
appreciate
whatever audience that you have you know
it's just hard because
you see where you want to be and when
you're not there yet you sometimes go
damn it why aren't i doing this
and then you kind of forget that hey you
still got something going on so
it is a struggle to think about um
for anybody in any level of
entertainment because it's happening all
over the place
the advent of technology is making it
it's changed the game you know all these
tick tockers and all these kind of
people
they wanted to be in the entertainment
business before this
and now they've changed the
entertainment business and made this the
entertainment business
look i've talked about this before look
at modeling five years ago we used to
clown instagram models we used to be
like oh she's an
instagram model let me tell you
something now
those are the the only models those are
the real models now
the ones that got 300 000 followers and
they got sponsorship and they got like
you know you go on there
they got a story about bang hey drink
bang oh my god
look at these new phone cases those now
are
the models who are making money so the
the business changes
it evolves and we got to change with it
so i hope that answers your question
all right next up working this entire
pandemic
zero days off places opening i wanna
hang with friends
my family trips okay
this is just one of those things where
you you have to try to balance
your personal life with your family life
with your like you know
you you're i see because i know where
you're coming from you're like i'm
working
all the time zero days off so i can
support my family so they can have the
lights on and eat
and have all the things and luxuries
whatever small or big that they have
you feel like hey that's my part can i
have something for me
i get that but you know
family people families especially kids
kids
you know people they feel entitled they
feel like well listen you
you you had me so that's your obligation
is to take care of me
you know what i mean so that's just the
attitude that a family has
so what you got to do is you got to find
a way to make time for both
and express how you feel about it to me
you have to sit down with your loved
ones and be like
hey make sure you spend time with them
and let them know you know
i need some time for me too um i'm going
to go do this
it's not one or the other you got to
find a way
to do both but don't be resentful about
it
because that's going to breed negative
feelings you you don't want to have
negativity around it at all you have to
remember your family loves you even if
you're working all this time and they
haven't been able to see you or spend
time with you they love you they want to
spend time with you they don't
they're selfish for your attention and
affection so remember it comes from a
good place
so you come from a good place too i'm to
give you this time but
on saturday i'm going to go hang out
with my boys because i haven't seen them
either and they want to spend time with
me too and i want to spend time with
them
love you all to death and i'm going to
prove it to you because of
a b and c or i'm going to do this this
and that so there's a way to do both man
just don't be bitter and angry and
resentful about it find a way to come at
this with it with love and affection and
remember it all is coming from a good
place and these outside forces are
messing with our lives
don't let them win all right
good luck buddy
this is a here's a good one
i hate this dude's name because this is
my girl's breath
smells like stinky tofu and i don't know
how to tell her help we all have this
listen not just about the breath but
it's like we all have something
when you start getting close to someone
they you start to have their whatever
their traits are whatever that
thing is that you don't like about them
and it's something that they can
actually change right away so that they
can affect and breath
is one of those things you know it's
like i sit in my chair all day
or i sweat i'm a big guy so at the end
of the day
you don't even realize how funky you are
my girl said to me like
i need you to take a shower at night
before we go to bed because there's some
smells coming off
you that you know and i'm like okay i
can respect that
again it's all about coming at somebody
with love coming at somebody with
respect you know it's all about how you
say this
you know because let me tell you what
happens your girl's breath funky
it bothers you so you don't now you do
this
you avoid kissing her you avoid intimacy
like that
because she got funky breath because
you're not trying to hurt her feelings
but let me tell you what happens because
you doing that
she starts to feel like you don't like
her she starts to feel like
there's something wrong with her and
then she's starting to feel insecure
because of how you're reacting and
coming at her and now you've caused a
problem
without just because you just didn't
come at her nicely and be like
you know of course you're not gonna go
yo funky breath unless you have that
kind of relationship too though if you
have that kind of like whatever
back and forth but no it's just a nice
way to be like honey i think sometimes
this this this and this it's gonna sting
at first it's gonna be a whole thing but
trust me
she would she would much rather know
that she got a funky breath problem
because
trust me the breath ain't just funky
with you it's funky with co-workers
it's fun you know what i mean so she
needs to know maybe people are acting
around her a certain way
because she driving them away because
she got funky breath you know it's like
you don't want to have somebody have
like you know
you got a booger in your nose and you
let me walk around with this booger all
day i'd be mad at you you'd be like ooh
but i didn't want to tell you because
i'm going to hurt your feelings i'd be
mad like you have me out in the streets
with a buggy on my nose and you're not
going to tell me i mean it's just that's
you know it it goes both ways there's
consequences to actually not being
honest
in this situation again the theme of the
day is like
how you have that conversation so find a
thoughtful
nice way to come at her about hey baby
i think there's an issue you know i love
you
please don't take this the wrong way but
your breath be
funky sometimes and i i and i think that
it's a problem and i just
it makes me uncomfortable and i want to
kiss you i want to be close to you but i
have trouble
because your breath i almost passed out
last night
don't say that but you get what i'm
saying just find a fun thoughtful way to
bring this up man
sometimes you maybe you wrap up a gift
and it's all
it's all dental stuff it's like a little
bottle of scope
a toothpaste a dental floss and
some mints and you just go baby boom and
then she might get the hint like oh [ __ ]
do i
does my breath stink and you're gonna be
like
enough and i need you to do something
about that
you know what i mean find a way but
don't let the resentment build up i'm
telling you
because you're causing a problem too by
not saying anything because of the
actions you're taking
to avoid it good luck
last one was in an argument
with a friend and he said shut up
derogatory homosexual term i won't say
i mean just because i don't know he said
[ __ ] okay
and sometimes you get flagged because
they don't they take things out of
context there'll be some idiot that
hears it and goes
oh he's saying this on this podcast this
is all in context so you know so the guy
said shut up [ __ ] should i
should i distance myself from him
well here's what i say about that okay
should you distance yourself from
someone because in the heat of an
argument they said something
really terrible to you i mean that's on
you i mean if you're trying to
please the you know the cancer culture
police
uh if you know what i mean like if
you're gonna put that on the internet
to be like i i got rid of a long
time friend because he said this to me
one time if you want those people to be
like oh good for you
but listen life is nuanced man it's not
black and white the internet is black
and white
the internet is they take one piece of
information that they've said
and then they label your whole life as
that
you know you know better than that we
have all said
things in the heat of an argument that
we should not have said
okay especially
we say things that if you know the the
person you're talking to
has a real problem with this particular
thing
those are the things in the heat of the
moment unfortunately we go to
first you know it's like that's what we
do
i remember her ex-girlfriend of mine she
was afraid of the dark we were fighting
i stormed out of the room and i turned
the light off you know and she was like
what do you do you know what i mean
why'd i do that i mean i was mad at her
so i did the thing i knew would bother
her the most
you know you know what i'm saying so
that's just that was terrible but that's
what we do in the heat of the moment
i think it's time to remember the heat
of the moment i think it's time to
cooler head should prevail
and you come to him later and be like yo
man i understand we have fights
i understand you know but
i don't think that that was appropriate
you know
if it's something you can't come back
from i get it but give that person a
chance
to be like yo hey man
that was pretty terrible i didn't
appreciate that
then that your friend who you know might
be like yo bro i know i'm so sorry i
didn't mean to say it like that that was
just totally out of hand i just was mad
you know you know you know you have to
give that person a chance to
you know make amends with you if the
amends can't happen you move on listen
i had a really good friend who i thought
was a really good friend of mine
won't say any names but he he caught
like
i'll give you an example i
have never met my father before okay so
i don't know my dad
it's always just been me and my mom
right my mom and i so
i was hanging with this buddy of mine
and his father would be around
and i said to him one day i said you
know what i've never met my father
before
and being around you and seeing you with
your father and how your father is
it makes me feel like oh man that's what
that must have been like it's really
nice to see that
well we got into an argument and he said
to me in the heat of the argument
that you know and you don't know your
father you know what i mean
like like wow right
so you know
the next day then the next day i got
like a really like
like there was no remorse so it was like
you know
a triple down on the same type of thing
so there was no way
and at that point it's like well i'm
never me and this person are no longer
friends and never will be friends again
forever you know because i tried
you know and it's just like so sometimes
that happens too so i'm saying this if
you go to your friend and he's like
well that's because you are you know if
he if he keeps going then you know oh
yeah i got to get away from this person
because a person
there's no there's nothing in them to
like make this right
you know sometimes that you just that
just happens too
you know what i mean but like that's
what i'm saying my point i'm trying to
make is
in this moment this ex-friend of mine
he thought he was going for the jugular
you know he thought that
oh let me find a thing that i could
really hurt him i mean that's sometimes
human nature is we
we try to say the thing that hurts the
person the most
but you know i'm just saying step away
from it
look at this person and see if you can
like make amends see if they want to
make amends
but don't just be like oh well i'm gonna
i'm getting rid of this person because
that's the end of it you know
he says this one thing to me because
come on life is nuanced
we don't live in we don't it's not life
is not black and white
right don't you don't want to be around
people who think
think things are black and white because
it is case by case
it is nuanced you know we can't just
that's the internet culture
of our world right now is to take one
statement and think that that's
the end-all be-all i'm telling you
there's
there's nuance to everything and
sometimes you have to just step back
from that
and just give yourself a moment you know
so
i wouldn't suggest you just step away
from him give her give it an opportunity
because
this is your friend to find out what the
hell is going on
in my case i'd have been having troubles
with this particular person for like
two years before that it just escalated
into
it and then that was the breaking point
you know and so
you know you don't want to let that and
i and my what i regret is not
saying something two years earlier like
yo i feel like something's going on
between us like why are you acting like
this with me
you know i think you know i look back on
it now like
i probably could have avoided it coming
to like a head
to that point so you don't want this to
happen to you where you know you're
going to have this as
in your check box and then two years
later you're going to be like you did
this you did this you did this you did
this
and then boom now you guys are no longer
friends you know because it's not it's
not fun that way
so but anyways good luck with that man
uh i hope that helps whatever
i'm saying and i hope all this when i
every time i do this it helps you
in any any way just no i'm just trying
to be a friend to you out there
like you guys are as a friend to the
podcast riffing with griffin but
that has been real world advice from a
grown ass man
thanks for watching all right guys well
that's it for uh this week's
episode of riffing with griffin and i
want to thank you all for being here
thanks again to the lovely rachel thanks
for everybody that's sent in their
questions on real world advice from a
grown-ups man i tried to answer as many
of them
as i could on instagram but you know
it's valentine's weekend so
i did as many as i could and you know
just look out for that in the future i
like to do it on
an instagram question then i take those
questions because i like to like
screenshot the
the question itself and put that up on
the thing as you guys saw
so thanks there and remember i'm always
i'm gaming every day on eric griffin
gaming
uh i try to put as many videos as i can
up on youtube i'm kind of lacks on that
sometimes but you can still just go to
eric griffin gaming please subscribe be
a subscriber
you know and then on saturdays i play i
do private war zone matches with the
friends and fans i do a private lobby i
set up the war zone match so if you play
call of duty and you want to do that
you know i get like 70 80 90 people that
come and we're playing against each
other you know what i mean that it turns
out to be a pretty fun time
so i do it for a few like four or five
hours on saturday morning started at 10
a.m pacific time so make sure you check
that out
and once again thank you for being here
i appreciate all the support
even you haters out there people doing
reaction videos
love you too you know keep keep doing
your nonsense because it's you know hey
maybe it's making people watch me more
uh either way thanks a lot take care
i'll see you next week
you